welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and if you're one
of the last of us that actually enjoyed
part two then this is the video for you
that the both of you though there's a
lot of people online saying that the
game is a big golf swing in a Miss
there's actually some cool Easter eggs
in it definitely are worth talking about
throughout this video we're gonna be
breaking down the best of them and what
you might have missed on your
playthrough obviously there will be
heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
had a chance to finish the game yet then
I highly recommend that you turn off now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
for videos like this every day and
please drop a thumbs up if you enjoy it
without the way thank you for clicking
this and let's get into our breakdown of
the Last of Us part 2
ok so Sony loved dropping their tech
into games across the board there's a
bunch of consoles lying around and you
might have spotted these whilst playing
the game not only is there a character
that Ellie brutally stabs in the neck
was playing a PS Vita because I'm
guessing she must be an Xbox fan but
there's also a ps3 in the game when
you're going through you genes that will
home away from home you can actually
find a PlayStation 3 in this room The
Last of Us part one was of course
released on the PlayStation 3 and it
quickly became one of the best games on
the console we can see next to it there
are other classics by Naughty Dog
including jak and daxter uncharted 2 and
what looks like it could be the box art
for uncharted one underneath it in the
Last of Us part one timeline the
cordyceps outbreak actually happened
just before the PlayStation 4 was about
to be released and thus this is still
seen as the height of gaming technology
I think all the calendars in the game
actually also stopped at 2013 which
shows that the world ended then little
did they know though the world actually
ended in 2020 because yeah this this yes
sucks
there are also some videotapes in
Newton's secret room that give you an
idea of what the guy was actually into
these are M I can't really say it on
YouTube without getting demonetised
but let's just say they would feature on
a website that has the word hub in it
and begins with a P the first is dong of
the wolf which is a play on the fake
movie in the first game called dawn of
the wolf
and there's also one called smash
Brandis couch which is a reference to
well I'm sure you can guess we don't
find one called Nathan snake or Naughty
Dog but hey if you want to use them guys
go ahead
Nathan snake going into uncharted
territory definitely sounds like a
winner to me now uncharred also pops
back up in the game when we see a
picture of Nathan Drake nolan north he
voiced the character didn't even know he
was in The Last of Us part two so it's
clear that the creative team hid this
away from well pretty much everyone keen
explorers may also come across a Nathan
Drake's ring during that time at West
Lake Bank the lobby is lettered with
infected however if you make your way to
the vault and use the code sixty 2306
you'll gain access to the inner workings
of it and the safety deposit boxes here
you'll find Nathan Drake's ring which
has the words SiC parvis magna engraved
into it
this means greatness from small
beginnings which is sort of a mantra of
Naughty Dog who built themselves up as a
game studio over the past couple of
decades before beating themselves over
the head with a golf club and spitting
on their legacy I'm just kidding Abbie
yeah you know you know I love you stay
away from me
speaking of Abbie when playing is her in
Seattle it's actually possible to find
the precursor rope from jak and daxter
quite early on when you're exploring
buildings they all will be located in a
room on a table this is listed as a
strange artifact however fans of the jak
and daxter franchise will know its true
name it also appeared in the Uncharted
series - and seems to be somewhat of an
easter egg Naughty Dog like to leave in
their games I mean come on it's it's
literally an egg shape in addition to
this you should also be able to find a
Jack X combat racing arcade machine when
working your way through the game this
was only available on the PlayStation 2
but it still shows just how much a
naughty dog like to seed their games
into other titles when going through the
WUF base you should also be able to see
someone playing jak and daxter on the
Vita in addition to this neil druckmann
the game director can also be found in
the game - no he's not the guy that
spits on Joel and even had to come out
and say this however if you explore
Seattle is Ellie you should
able to come across his trading card or
rather dr. Oakman go off the beaten path
and into one of the run-down buildings
and you should come across the little
easter egg to which ali remarks hello -
when discovering according to the
information on the card dr. Oakman was
once well respected but he was
ostracized after pushing human limits
with very fourth-wall breaking the code
says that he moves about from location
to location and longs for the days when
all his subjects are seen as equal
there's also an issue of savage
starlight which is a comic book series
that's been laced throughout the games
early and y'all talk about it when
journeying to get some new guitar
strings and you can actually find a copy
of the comic in the game at one point
last there was two also references the
earlier game with a cute little toy that
can be found after alien diner first get
out of the storm there's a little
stuffed giraffe and Ali even yachts down
a couple of notes about it this is
obviously a reference of the prior entry
in which the character and Joel came
across some towards the end of the game
it was one of the most emotional parts
of The Last of Us that showed there was
still be in the world and it's
definitely cool to see it brought back
up here the photo of Joel's daughter
Sarah - pops up in Joel's house when he
go back to it after the character's
death Sarah of course was Joel's
daughter in the first game and she was
sadly killed during the opening I'm not
crying you're crying Allie also
discovers Joel's broken watch which
Sarah gave him is a present on his
birthday which actually shows the exact
time that she died Ellie of course sort
of became Joel's surrogate daughter and
clearly he did finally get over her
death and put the watch to rest as much
as I have mixed feelings on the game I
absolutely love to see these elements
pop back up here and it shows it just
how much Joel cared for Ellie we can
also see a white rabbit out of the
window and some snow just as you first
take control of Ellie in the last of us
there was a chapter in which she took
control of her - and killed a lovely
innocent white rabbit in some snow so
overall this imagery does indeed bring
up the iconography of stepping back into
her shoes through flashbacks you get a
lot of things filled in about their
relationship including one of Ellie's
birthdays here we get a number of cool
little Jurassic Park Easter eggs that
show the movie actually existed in the
Last of Us world
The Last of Us world more like the lost
world I'm alright don't stop with em
puns
Joel tells her the plot of the movie
throughout the chapter and you can also
see a film accurate t-rex which you can
climb up geo remarks on a statue of a
large dinosaur and also calls it a
velociraptor which Ellie points out is
incorrect this is a nod to the film as
in real life Raptors were very small and
probably only half the height of a human
Spielberg and Cole made them bigger for
the movie in order to make them more
intimidating so this is a cool little
nod to that bit of movie trivia it's at
this point of the game you can also find
a pallet in the water which gel remarks
at them no longer needing in the first
game Ellie was unable to swim and thus
they had to use these to get her around
and it sort became an in-joke that there
were just tons of pallets everywhere
however in this game she can swim so
it's no longer needed when you go to sea
out like gate west to you'll find a safe
that needs the code is zero four five
one to unlock it this is actually a
famous game code that appeared as a
combination for multiple locks across
the medium it's popped up in deus ex
bioshock alien isolation system shock
thief and a lot more I had no idea about
this
so shout outs the GamesRadar for
pointing it out and it's gonna be a code
that I try on every lock before googling
to see what the safe combination is be
honest you google the safe codes to
don't you now there's actually a lot of
games that use it and there are multiple
Supercuts on YouTube that go over every
time it's popped up in a game before it
just seems to be a running joke at this
point but I'm telling you if I see you
safe or a door I'm using it and lastly
is a reference of the movie taken Ellie
is of course on a quest for revenge
throughout the game and at the end of it
she tracks ABI down and almost beats her
to death however Ellie has a change of
heart and decides at the last minute not
to murder her and she lets her and lab
escape this is a reference to the Liam
Neeson movie taken in which he says down
the phone I will find you and I will
forgive you I'm just kidding that that's
that's it I've ruined the video anyway
that's the best Easter eggs in the game
I'm sure there's a ton that I didn't
come across but those are the ones that
stuck out to me the most
now obviously I'd love to hear
which ones were your favorite and if you
found any that we missed comment below
and let us know and if you enjoyed this
video then please drop a thumbs up and
make sure you check out our full story
breakdown and ending explain which is
going to be linked at the end we go over
the ins and outs of the plot and the
final few scenes so it's definitely
worth checking out if it left you with
any questions if you want to support the
channel from as little as 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below
we massively appreciate you and as a
thank you you get access to content
early if you want to come chat aside for
the show either follow us at heavy
spoilers or click the discord link in
the description below every month we
give away free movies to be + subscribe
to the channel and this month II can
when the MCU and finicky Saga box set
and all you have to do is comment on a
video and make sure you subscribe with
notifications on the more videos you
comment on the more you have a chance of
winning so make sure you get involved
the one is going to be chosen at random
on the 15th of July and the set will be
shipped out from name to ever get
surprised it's the best of luck that
everybody takes part Cheers
[Music]
you
[Music]
you